all right teen white the let's not and
say we did attack D for my opponent is
saying that the stream is muted alright
let's see if I I believe that alright
let's go here maybe I want to play g3
Bishop g2 something a little bit
different from this
however with c5 maybe I want to do
something else huh
let's go with this so we're entering I
think what we call this is what Queens
gambit declined tirage right when
there's this great tension between these
pawns and there's some very well not
some there's a lot of symmetry we're
making identical moves and is my
opponent gonna still follow with this no
the tension has been released I want to
recapture towards the center now my
bishop will have play on this diagonal
and I think right here there is now
maybe a problem for black because I have
an opportunity for a structural change
but to be a bit more specific it's a
structural change with tempo so I'm
really considering c5 right now and then
that will secure me a three versus two
majority and that will be my plan it's
not always the easiest thing to come up
with in a chess game maybe the most
difficult phase for people in the middle
game but sometimes the pawn structure
gives those hints lets you know you can
run forward that and I'm gonna do this
with the follow-up of Bishop b5 I'm
looking to remove this Knight
so that my opponent cannot get this
central break-in so easily
it's pinned right now I think this is
the correct way to retreat the bishop
does need to keep a close eye on this
squares otherwise I play Bishop f4 and
things are wonderful I don't know that
there's a need to take this Knight just
yet
what about just castle and then rook e1
I like that maybe I can force
maybe I'll only take after a six and if
that's the case now I can take the
knight and after the recapture you'll
note that the bishop then does not have
the a six square available so maybe by
just holding off on this capture maybe
only after you know it's it's hit what I
take this is still just by having
pressure maybe it may be a better way to
view this is that just the threat of
taking the knight is is better than just
taking it all right what's that line the
threat is better than the execution or
something like that so anyhow I have a
three versus two on the Queen side my
opponent okay now I'm gonna I'm gonna
run forward that or should I still just
back up no I'm gonna take what I was
saying I have a three versus two on the
Queen side my opponent is a two versus
one in the center so I want to make sure
of why and I'm actually not liking my
decision time to think of it
yeah that's a nice move that's a nice
move right there well here's the plan I
have a plan I promise I do have a plan
here I don't know how great it is but I
want to read I wanted to trade dark
square bishop
and once I have that I'll look to play
my knight to be six and this Knight to
e5
this right here is definitely a
sensitive point for black just like in
my game earlier if you were here earlier
to watch my game that I should have lost
against lucid chess it was a Catalan I
was playing the black side and the
knight jumped into c5 I ended up taking
and he just turned out to be a great
liability and so yeah anyhow I'm seeing
that happening in this position as well
in that game there wasn't d5 pawn that I
had around and this right here it does
provide a flight square for my
opponent's king but it's also weakening
now especially with g5 and these moves
right here are chasing it's a case of
chasing my bishop away two squares that
it really wanted already go to I was
saying that I wanted to get the darks
for bishops off the board and now that
has happened without really any time
passing for me
so recapture towards the center let's
have a good reason not to I did think of
Pont X I was for some reason envisioning
that my rook was still on f1 but towards
the center I do have a flight Square not
the greatest one in the world but I go
with that and now I think it's gonna
happen
am I talking about I'm talking about
getting my knight to here do I want to
do that right away is it even needed
right away not gonna do it I want to get
here can my knight be very annoying here
am I going or should I be going
somewhere else
maybe I should have done this is f6
gonna be a move and then II five somehow
hopefully my night could be disruptive
enough
see six still has my attention okay
let's get there and now this could be a
big problem
okay giving up the exchange here and now
what do you do in response I want to not
give up my ID this guy is he's unhealthy
I don't want to allow this see pun for
deep on exchange just like again
referencing that earlier game out of the
Catalan that c5 advance is one that I
would like to get in because this the C
pot in that position just as it is in
this position is a liability for as long
as it's on the board it's backward
doesn't have any buddies no helpers no
other pawns that could support it
it's Queens Queens that have to are the
Queen right now that has to watch over
that guy okay and now what's my rook on
anyone doing nothing
let's get him doing something so how my
pieces are working at this point less
than a minute and now I play Knight here
there's Queen takes maybe bump my
let's bump up here maybe I could get him
b4 hey I'm real I want to get rid of
this night okay now I'm gonna be able to
get rid of him I thought just rook here
would have been better and I would take
with the rook not because of I I'm not
seeing that I have something against
this pawn but I really don't want this
structure to take place and now I'm
gonna retreat just here because I still
want to focus on maybe this pawn maybe
give something back and now I am going
to take this Queen is unprotected so
maybe I could take this pot at some
point okay I'm not going to take again
I'm just gonna double up files are
opened if you have the exchange create
pawn exchanges you open files by doing
just that so something needs to be done
with this guy and I've just pre move on
and now what seventh-ranked pieces are
following no good defense rook here mate
happening very soon no good solution
no time either pigs Queen has to give
herself up otherwise it is mate unless
she plays here mate in one at least okay
no time I could game she taco let's back
up and I think this is a miniature
lesson in what pawn structure right here
decision time well for one I don't know
that you should really even take right
now I mean I I think it's okay
but maybe be maybe still play the
mimicking game it's not the greatest
thing to continue to do eventually it
catches up with you and it'll turn out
to be bad but I think it's still quite
alright for you to run with this advance
and then you know force me to make a
decision do I take do I release the
tension do I move my bishop and then you
take and then maybe follow up with b5
this should be seven so consider a six
at this point but let's just assume that
okay yeah you did capture here the
bishops decision to play to d6 opposed
to e7 should be a it's a big decision
c5 with the structural change if it's on
d6 c5 or excuse me c5 structural change
and with tempo if it's on e7 I don't get
that tempo so that's one of the main
differences and knowing that now maybe
Bishop e7 is gonna be a better thing to
now run with Bishop e7 if I'm playing c5
maybe you could post up on e4 I'm not
100% sure but just that if there's one
quick point to make just know the
difference between d6 and d7 in this
case my opponent is typing that they
were looking for a five push and thought
it would
okay to bring the bishop back to c7 well
you never really ended up getting that
e5 move in so you have you playing with
definitely some plan in mind but I think
the idea to get this pun advancing is
just much too difficult because how I
can be following up in these in these
cases here with putting pressure on a
piece my bishop coming out getting ready
to eliminate a key defender of this key
supporter for this e5 advance so I don't
know that you should be looking to get
an e5 right here right now more
development maybe Bishop e7 or my the
most technical one that I'm seeing is
really to not take on this square just
yet and play a six but if it does get to
this point maybe it's best you do
consider Bishop e7 instead of d6 okay
let me let me close out good game she
taco